the Last of Us part two official story
trailer oh boy here we go if you guys
heard it's in a controversial week for
the Last of Us part two Naughty Dog and
all that included all those leaks that
happened yeah I did end up reading some
of them I'll talk about some of my
opinions towards what may be true about
said video game if anything I'm more
more so bummed of the reception that
it's getting from fandom before the
games come out that's not exactly an
attack against fandom and that's not
exactly a defense for the Last of Us
part two either it's just a bummer
really because the Last of Us was the
video game that got me back into gaming
that got me back into completing video
game as a lot of you guys as well I've
been really anticipating this game so
it's just a bummer when you you know
like something that was so positively
anticipated has now been getting so much
backlash off of its leaks name just
being honest anyway I'll talk more about
that afterwards but in the meantime
let's see what's in store with a story
trailer okay
I know you wish things were different
[Music]
wow so beautiful still looks great huh
I know you wish things are different
what a weird ironic way to start down
the trail
[Music]
I'm leaving tomorrow
do this smart believing Jackson
vulnerable do they just get to get away
with this
how'd you find us
[Music]
hello the music tone and the atmosphere
is still cool
I really will be naked
[Music]
there's a cost there
[Music]
what could have killed you maybe you
should have had a lot of ABI it's
wondering if - they're gonna try to you
know show some of that I mean I'm gonna
give the game a chance and before I go a
little further that really quick I mean
I think the trailer itself of what we
got here is pretty great I love the tone
I love the atmosphere I love the mood
it's pretty much everything that we've
come to expect from the Last of Us part
two by this point in terms of being a
story trailer I wonder how much they
reworked any of this in the editing room
where they're like maybe there's a
halfway point where we can hint debt
that we're not really gonna be using
Joel but we can at least hone in on the
using Elly portion of the game I don't
know I think like in terms of a cool
cinematic story trailer I thought it was
a gripping trailer that being said the
reason I'm gonna give it became a chance
regardless of whether or not the leaks
are true it seems like they are there
was a video game I don't know if you
guys have played it yet probably happens
it's one of the most popular video games
of all time Metal Gear Solid 2 Sons of
Liberty Metal Gear Solid you play a
Solid Snake and it was this glorious
game m/l Gear Solid 2 is one of my
all-time favorite video games and in
that game majority of it you're not
playing as Solid Snake you're playing as
some guy named ridin and I know there
was still like a little bit of backlash
that occurred with the fact that you
weren't playing a Solid Snake for
majority of the game but I think for the
most part it became a rather beloved
video game I do think though however if
that game had a leak that you're not
playing a Solid Snake and you're playing
as right and for like 95 percent of that
video game I would imagine there would
be an uproar from the fandom community
now it's not exactly the same thing with
The Last of Us
because I mean there's been multiple
trailers you can feel like we've been
misled and then of course with the
political climate that we're living in
it's easy to take the plot points that
we're hearing about sort of make it
about potential political reasoning
behind the game that's kind of why I
haven't been infuriated by it because
I've more so been hearing about like SJW
crap instead of actually taking time to
absorb the the plot points that occur in
the video game so my mind hasn't even
been thinking about the actual plot
points it's been so more thinking about
the way how this has become a political
argument right but looking at the actual
plot points itself I can see it going
both ways I can see myself getting
really upset like playing the game
switch to this abba character halfway
through you're taking characters that
are hairs on the last one and you're
shifting the perspective and making them
villainous I could see that being a
really upsetting thing but I also think
that with the amount of attention to
detail in time they've taken developing
this game not just in terms of graphics
and world building but also storytelling
that maybe just maybe I'm giving it a
chance because there's one thing to hear
plot points it's another thing when
you're playing a video game for several
hours on end you're getting absorbed
into the storytelling into the moment
that when you're getting the full
context it could actually work I don't
know if it will I have no idea if it'll
actually work initially hearing it it is
off-putting I'll admit that when you
when I initially hear it I'm like the
idea of what happens to Joel Ellie be
imbued as a villain and then playing is
this a B character like first time here
like that's not what I wanted you know
and maybe this is me just being hopeful
because of the fact that I've been
looking forward to this game for so long
and how much passion has been put into
this project there's a part of me that
thinks the the concept of shifting
perspectives can be cool I just really
would rather give it a shot to see how I
feel based off of actually playing the
game I know there's gonna be some people
who are gonna play it out of morbid
curiosity at this point who are really
loathing what they've heard but are
gonna give it a shot anyway probably
going in with a negative mentality and
there's gonna be some people I'm sure
who will probably absolutely refuse to
play the game and there's probably gonna
be some people like me who are being a
little bit more hopeful that perhaps
hearing just the actual beats of the
story don't work for them but maybe
through playing the video game it'll
actually work
like I said metal gears
all at - if I had heard that I would
have been annoyed but playing the game
itself I love that video game but they
didn't just you know Bob saw okay
major difference here cuz that game did
something where it's like you're seeing
Solid Snake through the perspective of
riding through a lot of the videogames
so shifting perspectives I think can be
cool but they don't kill off Solid Snake
so that's a major difference
automatically with that video game I
think it's a bold move I'm gonna play it
and I'll give my honest opinion of the
video game after all so none it might be
the first video game review I've ever
done on this channel just because of how
much the first game means to me but yeah
there's one thing that really does know
place it is it is what happens or Joel
now what they do with Joel what I'll say
about that is if they only do things
just for like subvert expectations or
shock value instead of really doing it
for strong storytelling purposes where
you can really be absorbed into the
perspective of a B then that will be
very frustrating at the end of the day
everything is all about execution still
bums me out for all the negativity it's
been getting and I'm not saying it's
it's not deserved it just sucks when
something that you've already sold
yourself on that you're gonna love is
now getting so much hate you know are
you guys they're gonna play The Last of
Us part 2 let me know your thoughts down
below I love this story trailer I love
all the trailers and clips we've gotten
of the game so far
I'm sure regardless the gameplay will be
a total blast and I'm sure there'll be a
lot of things on the to think of like
Game of Thrones Season eight you know
like there was a lot of actual in-depth
storytelling things that were not as
good as the prior season five on a
technical achievement scale there's a
lot of beautiful things that HBO had
never done before that they really
pulled off and maybe worst case scenario
that's what we can get with this video
game ok the storytelling things still
upset me but there's technical
achievements that were completed in this
video game that I had an experience in
any other games before and that made it
worth it so that's probably even a safe
guarantee just really one of like older
doctor was trying to salvage the love
anyway guys buddy let me I forget to
still play the game or not leave your
thoughts down below subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell to get notified
got a YouTube video up last but not
least Andrew Hayes Andrew Hayes how's it
going dude Andrew Hayes has been one of
our longest patrons he's been on this
channel before a gamer himself he has
his own YouTube channel often talks
about movies and wrestling whatnot
Andrew I just wanna give you a sincere
shout-out buddy we were doing a live
stream on Action industries YouTube
channel Ben Bateman and you got from the
Schmo down you popped up in the chat and
then we started riffing about you for a
little bit just how much of a really fun
generous sweet human being you are I
just want you to know I love you dude
and I hope you enjoyed this game if you
end up playing it or not yeah I just
want to take a moment out to say thank
you because bringing you up in that
stream and knowing that we actually had
a chance to become real buddies you mean
a lot to me so thank you for being you
dude and I hope one day you do get to
play Wolverine on the big screen or in a
fan film whichever one